[Música]
experto novato impostor animadores hola
soy el intruso y motoki estás viendo
experto novato impostor averigüemos
quién es experto y quién miente nuestros
tres invitados serán
animadores
vamos
vaya no será fácil y imagino a los
animadores expertos haciendo volteretas
y muchas acrobacias y además se nota la
postura ellos siempre están así
otra vez
cómo explicarlo no están relajados sino
que ya estoy cansado
y animadora
muy bien tendrán tres minutos para hacer
las preguntas más importantes
me encantaría
piernas separadas y hacia abajo tengo
una pregunta para rachel bien que te
llevó a ser animadora en realidad fui
gimnasta por 11 años antes de ser
animadora soy no secundaria quise
aprender un poco más y por eso me uní a
al equipo de animadoras de mi escuela y
qué tal tu fui animadora en mi
secundaria por 4 años ahora soy animador
en la universidad de california o lo he
hecho por unos 7 u 8 años parte de la
pirámide eres
190 me gustaría estar en la cima pero no
cuento las hoy clinton nací para esto
ya sea frente a 7 personas o 70.000 me
gusta alegrar a la gente siempre quiero
animarlos hoy lo que el trabajo de
animación incluye acrobacias y
coreografías siempre estoy aprendiendo
un poco de todo animal es lo que haces
cuando un dj pone música o cuando sigues
rutinas que ya tienes en la mente
empecemos con los aplausos 5 6 7 8 así 1
2 3 4 5 6
1 2 3 4
cada paso lateral comienza con un
aplauso eso significa que van a empezar
con los brazos abiertos como una t desde
aquí dan un paso a la derecha paso una
palmada en dos lado izquierdo 3 4 2
veces más 5
678 sus brazos se abren un paso adelante
dos para sus arriba 3 y bajan en 4 atrás
mantener
la energía otra vez desde aquí den un
paso hacia la izquierda van a mover este
brazo como una serpiente
serpiente o pero mantén la pierna recta
y así luego flexionar la pierna
izquierda hacia atrás abren los brazos
en bay para arriba
una vez más
las coreografías para tu equipo
en esta temporada y si cuentan es solo
un excelente coreógrafo puede ser
algunos pasos parecían parte de una
coreografía cierto como él usándolo bien
hay muchos animadores masculinos
profesionales así es hola soy rachel y
soy animadora la sensación de hacer una
rutina juntos o incluso de subir al
escenario para actuar como equipo
sabiendo lo mucho que se ha trabajado es
increíble voy a enseñarles unos saltos a
mí me encantan los saltos pero no creo
que sea una opinión popular en el mundo
de los animadores por alguna razón a
nadie le guste hiciste saltos como
gimnasta también hice atletismo
y así es más así a salto con pértiga
pero hoy día un poco de todo crees que
pueda saltar bien con tu falda sí tengo
las medias como si de algo está bien
entonces cinco seis siete ocho en uno se
ponen en cuclillas un poco y aplauden en
2 milan hacia la esquina de esta forma
la pierna derecha debe estar adelante de
la pierna izquierda
y yo sí sí pero en realidad le pueden
poner su toque como un salto si la
seguridad es la primera vez que me rompo
la ingle si me ha pasado te lo agradezco
te has roto la ingle se rompe o se
desgarra
se desgarra creo yo de paso no hablemos
de las ingles
presten atención
7 8 1 2 3 4 5 8
hablemos de estos zapatos se ven muy
divertidos algo atléticos
con esos zapatos para saltar a pasos
para saltar
recuerdas algún momento en el que te
resultará difícil hacer este tipo de
saltos por eso nunca te ha pasado todas
mis habilidades de animadora me sirven
también en las prácticas de gimnasia
solo tengo que cambiar ciertos aspectos
estilísticos pero si es factible gracias
rachel
rachel parece muy flexible y capaz de
hacer todas estas cosas pero puede que
no sea por completo un animal porque
ella dijo que era gimnasta y salto con
pértiga solo que tal vez nunca se cambió
animadoras y hola soy audrey y soy
animadora
hoy les enseñaré unos pasos bien vamos
dinámicos explosivos
somos los invictos de highlander nada
nos puede igualar
sentí escalofríos escalofrío al animar
tienes que hablar muy alto que la voz
venga de tu estómago es casi como cantar
dijiste que era música cantas si bien si
en los mensajes que viene del diafragma
pero es mucho más que una octava más
baja es oye
[Música]
porque cuando todo es unísono y todo el
mundo proyecta la voz suena mucho mejor
que oye sabe bien el primer movimiento
es este van a apoyar su pierna izquierda
luego cruzar a la derecha y hacer una t
para que sea más dinámico luego van a
aplaudir y girar qué haces para no
marearse al hacer este giro se llama
sporting
si casi es como si miras a un punto de
esta manera y lo sigues las animadoras
aprenden eso
es una técnica más común en el ballet es
decir también la usan los animadores si
lo hice por un tiempo
luego un paso a la derecha ahora deben
hacer esto pero 2 cortadora de césped
somos los highlanders
invito adictos donde los pechos
este en tu uniforme y puedes añadirle
2000 eso es cierto he visto animales que
también lo hacen
un poco de actitud
eres increíble y mi estrategia para hoy
sólo fue ser yo misma en realidad para
mí otra y fue la más segura si también
no quiero cometer el error de
generalizar pero tiene el aspecto
estereotípico de animador porque es
rubia y
así nos enseñó la verdadera animación
pienso que quizás sea novata porque ella
no para que lo hacía en la universidad a
ver si va o es algo por lo que le paguen
tal vez tenga una beca es cierto sí sí
ya tenemos una respuesta hagámoslo bien
decidido y ahora también
[Risas]
[Música]
queridos animadores que cuentan
acérquese que venga el equipo y ya te
liberamos un poco por favor no se enojen
si fallamos terrible mejillón hablando
creo que me tendré que ir a preguntar
wynton
creemos que tú eres el experto estamos
seguros de eso sentí como si estuviera
en tu equipo de animadores y creo que la
experiencia se notó sí
[Música]
cuéntanos tu experiencia soy uno de los
primeros animadores masculinos de la nfl
los rams ha sido una experiencia gracias
bien ya también a malata y empecé a
bailar ya animar en la secundaria a los
16 en 2018 decidí probar con la sele y
rams estoy en mi cuarta temporada soy
capitán este año y ha sido una gran
temporada
1 - ahora sólo quedan 2 kevin
y pensamos pensamos que eras la novata
tal vez porque nos enseñaste una porra
si pude sentir tu ánimo y me encantó la
voz que proyectas te para hacer tu
rutina eso fue escalofriante
justo ahora esto no me lo esperaba
porque pensé que encajaba en el
estereotipo de animadora pero sí dijo
que en el presente no soy animadora pero
si lo fui en la serie dentaria como hace
6 años
sólo fui animadora por 2 años yo amo la
danza soy bailarina y quiero continuar
mi carrera de hip hop y la ugr no ánimo
en la usb
lo que les enseñé era en realidad una de
las porras de mi instituto y solo le
coloque el nombre de la mascota o ese
ere que tienen que decir a su favor
pero no lo sé te veía un poco asustada
tos para saltar
un poco dolida no voy a mentir pero
también no entiendo creo que estaba un
poco nerviosa hoy por eso no inspira la
confianza necesaria notamos que eras muy
atlética pensamos que eras una gimnasta
muy buena pero que decidiste dedicarte a
la animación fui gimnasta y luego empecé
a animar en el segundo año de secundaria
ahora soy animadora del equipo de la ufc
vaya es increíble es genial 5 6 7 8
gracias por darnos suscriban se comenten
y apoyen este vídeo